we all want to be happy but the majority
of us have no idea what to do see the
Japanese have a concept called ikigai
which roughly translates into a reason
for being you need to have a purpose for
being here but this is easier said than
done because there are four components
that you need to check off in order to
achieve ikigai the second component for
ikiga needs to be something that the
world needs see we've been hardwired to
feel good when we know that we're needed
in a community back in the day when we
were hunters and gatherers this was easy
everyone played an important part the
cook was just as important as the hunter
back then whenever you put in work you
could see the immediate positive effects
your efforts had on others but this
isn't the case nowadays most of us work
in offices being given small roles in a
massive company where even if we work
our butts off it's hard to see the
positive effects our work has on the
rest of the world it feels like our work
isn't really helping anyone you need to
find something that the world needs
something that you can do that will
create a visible positive effect on
those around you follow us for more
helpful tips